rye editors loot criminals run over
police officers with cars and president
trump declares he'll unleash the
military if chaos continues i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well chaos continued last night
because once again
our government has failed to protect you
the law-abiding tax-paying citizen
it is apparently better to be a rioter
and looter in major american cities than
it is to be a law abiding citizen if you
were law abiding you were locked in your
home
at sunset last night in los angeles
curfew went into affected variously
either 5 p.m
or 6 p.m last night and apparently this
is all okay
it's all okay because after all the
protests are legitimate and their
outrage is legitimate now
you can believe that protesters who are
exercising their first amendment rights
in law abiding ways are doing something
perfectly american you can even agree
with the agenda of the protesters with
regard to police brutality and even if
you disagree
on their broader agenda which is that
america is endemically racist and that
america has to be remade from top to
bottom you can still agree that
obviously them out marching
that's an aspect of americanism that is
quite good okay but
that does not mean that you have to
believe that rioting and looting ought
to be allowed to roam
our major cities and the attempt by the
media to conflate the rioters and the
looters and the protesters is absolutely
insane
they're doing it for political purposes
and it is hard not to believe that some
members of the media
are not thrilled with the amount of
conflict that is that is being generated
here
because how else could you possibly
explain the takes that are happening in
the media i mean
it's nearly impossible to explain
without some sense that people are
excited by the possibility that this is
going to be the tip of the spear
in breaking down the old ways in america
and remaking america
in some new unspecified way okay so last
night here's how events went you can
again the media coverage of this is
absolutely insane
last night the big story was not
president trump going to a church
last night the big story was that there
was mass looting in
new york city mass looting in new york
city there are police officers
shot or run over around the country okay
that is the big story this morning
that in the valley in in los angeles
there were people who were ransacking
van nuys the new york city people were
literally just taking cars to stores
hopping out of cars
breaking into the stores and stealing
everything while the cops were being
limited
by the mayor bill de blasio who's just
terrible at his job in every possible
way that it is possible
to be terrible at his job according
to the washington post four police
officers were shot early on tuesday in
st
louis police said in a tweet all four
officers remained conscious and
breathing before being taken away from
the scene the st louis metropolitan
police department said the officers were
taken to a nearby hospital
with non-life-threatening injuries they
were standing near a line all of a
sudden they felt pain said st louis
police chief john hayden
he said two officers were shot in the
leg one was shot in the foot one was
shot in the arm police had not
identified a suspected shooter or made
any arrests
as of early tuesday also
in a also there was a large peaceful
protest apparently in st louis before
200 people started involving themselves
in break-ins and looting and throwing
rocks and explosives at police officers
and throwing gasoline at police officers
so everything
is apparently hunky-dory everything is
going really well
meanwhile in new york city an nypd cop
was attacked and there is tape of it you
can see it happening by the way there
was a big controversy in new york
because apparently a member of nypd drew
his gun on somebody and was fired
yesterday and then the entire tape came
out and it turns out that somebody was
throwing bricks
at one of the police officers who was
standing right next to the guy
so we have tape of this nypd cop being
attacked we also
have tape of buffalo cops being run over
by a car
so everything is going great guys
everything is going really well the
the civil here's the thing about civil
disobedience it's supposed to be civil
okay civil disobedience means you are
not going to pay attention to like
traffic laws it does not mean
that you start throwing bricks at
officers or throwing gasoline at
officers or breaking storefronts to grab
a pair of shoes
that's not what any of this is about the
looting in new york city was
extraordinarily widespread last night
i mean it was very very widespread we're
going to get to the update
from new york city and andrew cuomo your
illustrious governor
a garbage sheep of a governor a terrible
terrible governor who's responsible i
mean
may i have a solution for andrew maybe
we should throw the looters into old age
homes
maybe that's the solution he's throwing
people with covet 19 into old days homes
apparently
the solution is to throw all problems
into old age homes in new york city so
maybe the governor of new york can do
that as well we'll get to
what's happening in new york and what's
happening in l.a and we'll get to the
media coverage of all of this
plus all of the controversy surrounding
president trump momentarily
first let's talk about the fact that if
you've got a little bit of um
of nervous tension right now you know
what a great way to take that out is
lose some weight and that means do some
exercise i'm a big fan
of crossroad why well because you know
you don't want to buy a cardio machine
you probably don't have room for
something like that and these days it is
possible you can't even run around
outside because hell you don't know
what's happening outside your front door
well crossroad has a solution
for you crossroad is reinventing the
home workout experience weighted ropes
that give you better feedback that makes
it easier for beginners to get started
and learn durable steel ropes with
ergonomic handles
patented fast clip system for swapping
rope weights fast i've done a workout
with crossroads several of them in fact
and i mean it is a workout it is a
serious serious workout it's easy to get
started with crossroads you just order
the ropes download the app and enjoy the
results you can choose between their get
lean or get strong
sets depending on your fitness goals or
get the best value for both sets with
the get fit bundle
and the workouts do vary they have
varieties of workouts you can track your
workouts you have map of your progress
on the free crossroad app crossroads so
sure you'll love the whole experience
they even offer a 60-day risk-free
guarantee so you really have nothing to
lose i mean the product is just
fantastic i've used it myself i can
testify to that if you're ready for a
new cardio and full body home workout
visit crossrope.com
shapiro get up to 40 off cross rope sets
plus free shipping when you check out
today
at crossroads.com shapiro that's my name
shapiro
crossrope.com shapiro go check them out
right now
crossroads.com s-h-a-p-i-r-o and get 40
bucks off cross rope
sets plus free shipping which is an
awesome awesome deal okay so
the the looting was was widespread in
new york city last night it didn't
matter that andrew cuomo had announced
the first new york city curfew since
since 1943 which was in the middle of
world war ii
okay so we had the first cur i mean new
york city has been the site of riots
before
and protests before he announced a a
full curfew
he's an idiot so he announced the curfew
at 11 p.m which makes perfect sense
because what you really want is like
five
hours of darkness to set in before you
actually declare the curfew genius move
here
by andrew cuomo and what was the
predictable result as we'll see
people running around in their cars and
just looting shops
and then running away i mean the looting
was widespread
nothing says let's get back to business
after covet 19 quite like
let's shut down all businesses in the
country particularly in new york city
and then just on the verge of reopening
let's let looters go in and just smash
and grab everything
after all insurance will cover something
here's andrew cuomo your garbage
governor of new york
in new york city i spoke to the mayor
the
uh there's going to be a curfew
in new york city uh
that we think would could be helpful and
uh more importantly there is going to be
an increase in the force in new york
city
uh were about four thousand officers on
duty
uh last night uh there'll be double that
tonight about eight thousand it's not a
question of
needing more personnel in new york city
okay just he's he's so bad at this
hey so you you issue a curfew order for
11 p.m
well turns out people are out on the
streets before 11 p.m and here's what
some of that looked like
here's some tape of the looting that was
happening in new york city you can see
people just walking right into these
stores in the background you can see
that that store that is being broken
into a giant crowd of people
do these look like people who are deeply
disturbed about the death of george
floyd or who
give two dams about george floyd
actually this is like people who are
desperately
protesting police brutality or does it
look like a great opportunity
to grab yourself a pair of shoes or
something okay and then
you saw this last night aldo was being
broken into because aldo obviously
killed george floyd
although his police brutality writ large
what you're seeing by the way is
corporations all over the united states
today
who are engaging in what they call
blackout day which is an attempt to
buy some sort of respite from the
looters and rioters the idea
you saw this all over the the sherman
oaks valley area people boarding up
their windows
in expectations of rioters and looters
and writing on the boards things like
blm we love george floyd guess what guys
ain't gonna save you
it ain't gonna save you and by the way i
would assume that no one is in favor of
george floyd dying
but the idea that you're going to buy
some sort of mercy from rioters and
looters
assumes the writers and looters give two
craps about george floyd
which they do not and they're not
they're not like attempting to
to say any differently it's amazing the
media's willingness to conflate
three groups of people people who are
protesting people who are riding and
looting in antifa
is unbelievable it's unbelievable so
they can have the dramatic footage
and so they can suggest that america is
on the verge of civil war and so they
can suggest
that protesters are the ones who are
breaking in and people can't be
contained their anger just can't be
contained
alternatively there are a bunch of
people who take advantage of bad
situations in order to riot and loot and
the veneer between civilization and
non-civilization is incredibly thin
i mean i think that's what we are seeing
in most of america's major cities over
the past week or
so is that the veneer is really really
thin that as soon as the expectation
goes away that you will be punished for
violating a law
then people just start violating the law
okay and by the way
people who are protesting believe this
is true about police officers that if
police officers with impunity can harm
people
and you will get more police officers
harming people i think that as a basic
set of incentive structures that's
correct
is one of the reasons why i'm not in
favor of qualified immunity for police
officers which is a doctrine created by
the supreme court in 1982 and basically
suggesting that even if you
work outside the scope of your authority
you should be granted some sort of
immunity but the same logic apparently
does not apply to you know
violent violations of law on a daily
level
it's been building up in places like new
york and seattle and la for a long time
as the mayors of these cities basically
declared that low-level violations of
law are totally fine
and then when it turns into outright
rioting and looting then they just let
it go for a week they just let it go for
a full week
okay so what are the riders and looters
want well why don't we ask one of the
lures so here's a looter
who was arrested yesterday in los
angeles talking to a member of
local fox and explaining what exactly he
was doing rioting and looting
why you out here man perry point blank
just like all my real ones trying to do
trying to get some money
explanation that's it trying to get some
dough that's it just out here for the
money yeah
pretty much anything to do with the
protest what happened in minnesota
i mean a little bit to do with that too
you feel me but not really i'm out here
for the dog
was it worth it obviously now i'm right
here hemmed up
yeah y'all see it man if y'all gonna get
some money do it right don't do it the
dumb way do it the smart
way so that's all good times
i'm just i'm very very pleased that the
media have decided to
wrap all of this up in a ball and then
declare that america is guilty for all
of it america writ large
if you're going to blame people see
here's the thing if you want to solve
problems you have to be specific
in your solutions and you have to be
specific in the person who you think is
the problem
but this entire conversation about
police brutality has been absolutely
non-specific
not only has been non-specific on police
brutality it's been non-specific on
america
more generally as we will see the media
basically just want to declare that
america is racist and evil and guilty
and terrible it's why you saw the
founder of black entertainment
television come out yesterday
and call for 14 trillion dollars in
slavery reparations
in order to stop the rioting and the
looting and the unrest and all the rest
of this
can you're gonna have to explain why it
is
that a white person who's never done
anything racist is supposed to kneel in
front of black people
as happened at some of the protests
yesterday in order to demonstrate
their fealty to the idea that america is
inherently racist wrong why is that why
does that fix the problem
why does that fix the problem why is a
non-racist person
being being shamed into doing penance
for a crime they didn't commit how is
that how is that fixing any problem
at all again we should all be in
solidarity with the idea that what
happened to george floyd is terrible
we're all on the same side
you can't read the transcript and not
see it as an atrocity the transcript
of that incident is awful it is awful
the transcript is people around the
office are saying to him
get off that guy he can't breathe for
like eight minutes and him not getting
up
is there anyone in america who doesn't
read that transcript and think that's
awful
but according to the media of course we
are deeply divided over george floyd
even though we are not divided over
george floyd even though no one is in
favor of police brutality
no one of whom i am aware is in favor of
police brutality
but guess what it ain't police brutality
when the police go arrest rioters and
looters
and the divided mind the media seem to
have about police officers
why aren't the police officers
protecting us and at the same time
police officers are racist and vicious
and cruel
it doesn't work that way okay so
meanwhile
the situation at the at the white house
got very contentious yesterday
it got very contentious because the the
president of the united states
started going after the governors and he
was pointing out quite correctly that
governors across the nation have failed
to perform their most basic duty
protecting the citizenry
you must protect the citizenry okay this
is your chief duty
john locke suggested not to get into two
basic philosophy here john locke
suggested that in a state of nature
that you have rights that pre-exist
government and the reason that you form
a government is to protect
those rights not to violate those rights
to protect those rights it is tyranny
for the government to lock you in your
home and tell you that as a law abiding
citizen you're supposed to pay taxes and
obey the law and now you're locked in
your home so we can let the rioters and
the looters run free on the streets
that is not an aspect of a decent
government that is an aspect of tyranny
and so president trump had some words
about that and of course the media
predictably went nuts on it we'll get to
that
in a moment first with everything going
on right now a lot of people are asking
if it's even possible to buy life
insurance at all and the short answer is
yes you can indeed buy life insurance
during a pandemic or during riots if you
have loved ones depending on your income
you probably should as an insurance
marketplace policy genius is in contact
with the life insurance companies on
their platform every single day
they're keeping track of all the changes
in the market so you don't have to which
means they can get you covered quickly
and for the best price
here's how it works policy genius
compares quotes from the top life
insurance companies in one place it
takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from the top insurers to find
your best price
this doesn't just save a lot of legwork
you could save 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape for free
so if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to take care
of everything so if you're one of the
many people looking to buy life
insurance right now but you're not sure
exactly where to start there's only one
place to start that's policygenius.com
they've got the life insurance they've
got the
auto insurance the disability insurance
all the insurance that you could
possibly need
be a responsible human being make sure
that your family is taken care of go
check out policy genius they'll find you
the best rate they'll handle the process
completely they'll get you and your
family protected and give you
one less thing to worry about go check
them out right now policygenius.com
again
that is policygenius.com
all right so president trump yesterday
he went off
on governors on a phone call saying why
the hell aren't you locking down
your states and making sure that law
abiding citizens are able to actually
roam your streets here's president trump
going off on governors correctly
get a lot of men we have all the men and
women that you need
but people aren't calling them up you
have to dominate if you don't dominate
you're wasting your time they're going
to run over you you're going to look
like a bunch of jerks
you have to dominate and
you have to arrest people and you have
to try people and they have to go to
jail for long periods of time
and those kids are all on camera they're
wise guys
okay he is correct about this the media
were very angry how dare he say this to
the governors
well considering the governors have
failed to prevent the destruction of law
and order in their areas
considering that they have completely
failed to do this trump is not wrong
okay so trump yesterday he does
oppressor in the rose garden
and at the same time the pressure was
going on this is what became the major
controversy of the day of course at the
same time the presser
was going on the the situation in
lafayette square which is right adjacent
to the white house
they're a bunch of protesters there and
they're being cleared with
with apparently smoke grenades
essentially
they're being cleared from the area now
the media later declared that president
trump
had done this in order to clear the area
so that he could walk over to the local
church at st john's which had nearly
been burned down
a couple of days ago for a photo op well
let's just be clear about this according
to u.s park police
they say that tear gas was never used
smoke canisters were deployed
which don't have an uncomfortable
irritant in them is according to neil
ogenstein
over at wtop the source says park police
didn't know trump would be walking
across the park several minutes later
park police say the reason the crowd was
dispersed with smoke canisters is that
at the moment
officers were being pelted with water
bottles another factor was that
protesters had climbed on top of the
structure at the north end of lafayette
square that had been burned
the day before that is park police's
side of the story
so that there's uh so they're saying
that basically there was indeed civil
unrest and that is why they were
clearing the power in any case as that
was going on president trump spoke in
the rose garden here was president trump
saying
that we're going to ensure that justice
is served for george by the way there's
there's an fbi investigation going on
the doj
is on this particular case trump has
been very consistent
in suggesting that he was horrified by
the tape so here is trump saying that
yeah we're going to do our best to to
find out what happened with george floyd
and then people will be prosecuted to
the full extent of the law
all americans were rightly sickened
and revolted by the brutal death
of george floyd my administration is
fully committed
that for george and his family justice
will be served
he will not have died in vain
but we cannot allow the righteous cries
and peaceful
protesters to be drown
out by an angry mob
he is exactly correct about this and
then he says
listen we're gonna end the riots and the
lawlessness this is not going to
continue here's the president yesterday
in the rose garden
on the split screen with all of the
protests and riots going on around the
country
i am mobilizing all available federal
resources
civilian and military to stop the
rioting and looting
to end the destruction in arson and to
protect the rights of law abiding
americans including
your second amendment rights therefore
the following measures are going into
effect
immediately first we are ending the
riots and lawlessness
that has spread throughout our country
we will end it now and then
he said listen if the mayors don't do it
i'm going to dispatch the military to do
it so i'm just going to note here
the same media who are very angry at
trump for not issuing a nationwide
lockdown order over covet 19
are now saying that he's a tyrant for
saying that if he has to he will
activate the military and he does have
the legal authority to do this he will
activate the military in order to stop
rioting and looting
so is it possible the media just hate
trump i sort of get that feeling here's
president trump yesterday
a number of state and local governments
have failed to take
necessary action to safeguard their
residents
innocent people have been savagely
beaten
like the young man in dallas texas who
was left dying on the street
or the woman in upstate new york
viciously attacked
by dangerous thugs if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property
of their residents then i will deploy
the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
okay so this was horrible according to
democrats and according to the media
this is tyranny and as we'll see the
media reaction here is extraordinary and
over the top and crazy
he does have the legal authority to do
this under the insurrection act the
insurrection act has in fact been
invoked before it was invoked in 1992
during the los angeles riots now in that
case
the governor who is then pete wilson a
republican in california asked the
federal government to invoke the
insurrection act so that the federal
government could send in troops and
quell the rioting that was happening
in south central los angeles okay but
you don't actually need
state permission in order to do that or
a state request in order to do that
in fact the insurrection act was invoked
over the objections of governor orville
falbes in alabama
in order to ensure that black kids could
go to school in the 1950s
at integrated schools governor president
eisenhower invokes the insurrection act
okay so the insurrection act is
generally invoked when local authorities
are not doing their jobs and protecting
the civil rights
of their citizens so the president does
have the authority
to do this sort of stuff so the
president
has real authority to do it and the
president by the way didn't say he's
going to do it he said if you don't get
your cities
and states under control then i will do
it and guess what he should
he should because guess because you're
an american tax-paying citizen you have
civil rights your civil rights are being
abridged and violated when you are
locked in your home so writers and
looters can roam free
if the president has to has to do this
and he shouldn't have to
i mean the fact is that mayors and
governors who fail should be held
politically accountable for their
failures
but does the president have the legal
authority to do this he does he does
have the legal authority to do this and
he was not guaranteeing he is going to
he was saying if you continue to let
this stuff rage out of control then i
will have to
but guess what many states are starting
to get this under control minnesota is
where this started and the unrest has
basically died down over the last three
days why because there are now heavy
boots on the ground from police
after the governor tim walls basically
activated the national guard and told
the minneapolis mayor to stop with his
nonsense and allow the police to do
their jobs
it turns out that writing and looting
were basically stamped out
okay so this was controversy number one
regarding president trump there is
controversy number two
regarding president trump and that was
the situation
right after this so president trump
speaks at the rose garden as he is
speaking
the police are firing tear gas at
protesters
in lafayette square so the original
story is that the they were doing this
in order to clear the path so that
president trump could go do a photo op
at st john's and the video
is disturbing because you see the police
who are
advancing on a crowd of people who seem
to mostly just be protesting like you
don't see anybody
who is committing acts of violence in
this particular video
and the police are dispersing smoke
grenades uh
in order to move people out of lafayette
square people saying these are peaceful
protesters why are you dispersing them
why are you why are you telling them to
leave
well okay this is about 25 minutes
before the mandatory curfew
in the city okay but beyond that
it is also a fact of the matter that
you do not necessarily typically if
you're going to have a protest i mean
just to be perfectly legally technical
about this
i'm not a huge fan of clearing people
who are
protesting in in public parks
just generally not not a huge fan of
that however if you've ever held a
protest one thing you know is that you
actually have to have licensing from the
police you're supposed to be licensed
with the local authorities
presumably that's not what happened here
and so the police move them out
according to the park police again i'm
just quoting the park police according
to the park police these people were
moved out because people were chucking
water bottles
at the cops and they were and they were
positioning themselves
on top of burned out monuments and all
the rest okay so that's
that's the situation then president
trump walks out
and he decides to walk to the church
we'll get to that in just one second
because this became the sort of flash
point
of course the implication was that trump
had ordered the clearing out of the park
in order so that he could do the sort of
macho pose in front of the church first
of all
if you are deeply troubled by the
president going and if you're more
troubled by the president going and
posing in front of a burned-out church
and vowing law and order then you are by
the fact that people burn the church in
the first place
then you are doing this wrong you are
doing this wrong whatever your feelings
about the photo op
nature of this sort of thing the fact of
the matter is that if you are more
disturbed
about president trump photo opting in
front of a burned out church
than you are about the fact that a cop
was run over last night in buffalo or
the fact that
cops were being shot in st louis or the
fact that stores were being looted
around new york or the fact that the
church itself was burned like two days
ago
then it's because you hate trump
truthfully
you can be outraged at both but you
really cannot say that this is this is
what's breaking the country i'm sorry
trump
clearing a park even if that's what
happened in the park police say it isn't
but even if that's what happened trump
clearing a park to stand in front of a
church
is not on it's not fascist it is not
tyranny it is not sandman square it is
not on the order of anything else that
is going on that is an actual threat to
the lives and
and rights of american citizens we'll
get to this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that i can say
with full confidence that expressvpn is
the best vpn
on the market and you need a vpn right
now because you're spending awful lots
of time online since you're all
confined to quarters expressvpn is not
going to log your data lots of really
cheap or free vpns make money by selling
your data to ad companies
expressvpn developed a technology called
trusted server that makes it impossible
for their servers to log
any of your info they're really fast
i've tried lots of vpns in the past many
will slow your connection down or make
your device sluggish i've been using
expressvpn for a really long time my
internet speeds are always blazing fast
even when i connect to servers
thousands of miles away i can still
stream hd quality videos with no lag
something else that really sets
expressvpn apart it's really easy to use
unlike other vpns you don't have to
input or program anything
just fire up the app you click one
button to connect it's so easy even your
grandparents could probably figure this
one out so
go protect yourself with the vpn i use
and trust use my link at expressvpn.com
today get an extra three months free on
a one year package that's
expressvpn.combenexpressvpn.com
ben to learn more never been a better
time to protect your data go check them
out right now expressvpn
them okay so then president trump walks
over to the
church so the park is cleared president
trump walks over to the church
holding the bible and there is this
photo op
and he is surrounded by some of his
staffers his chief of staff mark meadows
ivanka shows up jared kushner shows up
again i'm not a photo op fan generally
again i i don't like the idea that the
president of the united states is
supposed to be some sort of image-making
symbol i've never liked this sort of
thing
but is this supremely outrageous that he
went to stand in front of a historic
church that was nearly burned to the
ground by protesters last night
i don't feel this is supremely
outrageous really
i don't he brought a bible along with
him look this is is it a photo op
obviously it's a photo op
of course it's a photo op he didn't even
read anything from the bible of course
it's a photo op
i don't like these sorts of photo ops
but if the image that americans are
getting is the president
who's not going to allow churches to be
burned down then i'm kind of in favor
right if that's the image that's being
put out there a president who is not
going to allow
spaces to be taken over by looters and
rioters i'm kind of in favor
that didn't stop the episcopal bishop of
washington dc who oversees that church
from saying that she was outraged that
neither she nor the rector was asked or
told that they would be clearing with
tear gas so they could use one of our
churches
as a prop worth noting that this
episcopal bishop really doesn't like
president trump in the first place so it
is worth taking that
into account and then you have axios
reporting
that certain members of the white house
were not exactly thrilled with the
church
photo op one senior aide was telling
people that this is an iconic moment for
president trump a senior white house
official though told axios
that they were ashamed and disgusted
okay whatever your reaction
to president trump standing in front of
the church let's be real about what the
actual story in america is right now
widespread rioting across the nation
targeting of police officers
and a president who finally is getting
out of the bunker and telling people
that he is going to
enforce the law and now there better be
some damn follow-up because if i'm still
locked in my home and you're still
locked in your home a week from now
because rioters and looters are running
roughshod then the president was doing
empty photo ops and it means nothing
okay so the president better fulfill his
pledge to actually protect the citizens
and so must mayors and governors this is
the only reason
that government was instituted was to
protect your rights in the first place
and now the media reaction to all of
this is just insane
insane so they're pushing a couple of
different notions one
that looting and rioting are actually
good that they're like
the boston tea party two that the
writers and looters and the protesters
are on the same page
which is not in fact true the looters
are there to loot and the
and the protesters are there to protest
and they are not there for the same
reason
at all and then three the reason that
the rioters and the protesters are on
the same page is because america
is deeply deeply evil so
again the the this sort of process
of thinking is disturbing and it could
lead to the destruction of the country
i i wrote a book all about the
destruction of the country called how to
destroy america in three easy steps
it's coming out in july and when i wrote
it this is exactly the sort of stuff i
was worried about and then the pandemic
hit and i thought okay well
at least we can all come together around
shared values like
we don't like disease and even right now
i think that we should all be able to
come together around certain shared
values like it is bad when a police
officer kneels on somebody's neck for
nine minutes for no reason
and also writing and looting is bad but
apparently not and why is that not
why is that not a a thing
the reason that it is not a thing the
reason we can't come together is because
there are a group that there's a large
group of people i call them
disintegrationists in my book because
they're actually for the disintegration
of the country
disintegrationists who want to portray
america is nothing more
than an agglomeration of various
interest groups at each other's throats
constantly
and the portrayal of america's founding
principles as
deeply malign and evil the sort of 1619
project view of america
it bears fruit and those fruit can be
seen every day in academia they can be
seen every day in the media
the push for the complete destruction of
america is a unified body politic
because our history is evil our shared
philosophy is a lie
our culture doesn't exist our culture of
rights doesn't exist we're just a bunch
of competing interest groups locked into
this cage with each other
but that vision of the united states has
been promulgated by the media continues
to be promulgated by the media
and what's amusing is to watch in a very
dark way what's amusing
is to watch as politicians on the left
try to capture that sentiment
and then say and if you just vote us and
we'll solve that problem that is not a
solvable problem
it is not a solvable problem once you
suggest that america is corrupt
through and through that america racism
is in our dna as barack obama suggested
once you suggest that america is
incurably vicious
then no vote is going to change that
what you really need is dissolution of
the country
and by the way any attempt to cram down
a fundamental change from the top
is going to go without the consent of
the vast majority of americans who
actually sort of like the country
that's what's going to lead to more of
the country breaking apart
i'm i would be i'm bewildered and
saddened
and honestly like it brings you to the
verge of tears when you think that
the greatest edifice for human freedom
in the history of the world for human
freedom and prosperity
the greatest edifice ever the
philosophical underpinnings of the
declaration of independence and the
constitution of the united states are
being abrogated
and thrown out in favor of pure malign
politics
nasty disgusting politics that are
attempting to tear us
one from each other even though you know
your neighbor isn't in favor of rioting
and looting
you know your neighbor isn't in favor of
police officers kneeling on anybody's
neck
you know all that but you've been told
that america stands for police officers
kneeling on people's neck
and therefore riding and looting are
okay that's what the meeting that's what
the media are telling you day in and day
out it's what academia are telling you
day in and day out you can see it over
at cnn
okay so cnn again the stories of the day
are not president trump stands in front
of church i'm sorry that's not the story
of the day
the story of the day isn't even the
president suggesting that if the
local authorities don't do their job
then the federal government will do its
job
the story of the day is continued
destruction of law and order across the
united states
and the failures of local authorities to
do anything about it that's the story
of the day okay cnn's front page makes
no mention whatsoever of police officers
being targeted
they make no mention whatsoever of the
rioting and looting that happened in new
york city
last night instead the headline over at
the over at cnn is
trump responds with a strong man act
your most trusted name in news okay
we're gonna get to the media again
pushing
this notion that riots and looting are
okay because america is
is brutal and evil and also by the way
president trump's a dictator
so president trump if he tries to shut
down ryze and looting it's because he's
a dictator not because
it is the job of the government to
ensure that you are able to
go about your business in normal fashion
but because he's a dictator
we'll get to the media's coverage and
the democrats and this is all
insane it's insane sorts of stuff we're
going to get to it in just
one second first the double tumbler is
back but it is only available for our
most exclusive membership tier
all access the all-access membership
tier is our premier level of membership
all access members get to participate in
all access live our brand new
interactive programming featuring one of
the daily wire hosts
we hang out with you each night all
access members also get to join us for
real-time
q a discussions available on both the
website and the daily wire app
the all access lives they're a lot of
fun we did one of them last night we're
getting through this rough time
together and hanging out and joking and
i wear t-shirts which is of course
the big pitch i'll access membership now
includes two of the irreplaceable
leftist tiers tumblers they are
literally overflowing
with tears at the thought of this offer
finally all access members also get the
benefits of our other membership tiers
including an ad free website experience
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library
access to the show's mailbags the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
along
with dedicated editorials from mwah head
on over to dailywire.com
subscribe to join all access and get 15
off with coupon code shapiro right now
that is dailywire.com
subscribe we'll see we will see you
there you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so what we are seeing right now is is
the case from the media and the
democrats but i repeat myself
that the riots and looting are part of
the protests that the protests and the
riots and looting are all justified by
the innate evil of the united states
and therefore the president trump
attempting to crack down on the riots
and the looting
is a tyrant right that is the logic and
it's being openly pushed
by members of the mainstream media
openly pushed okay not not quietly
openly
chris cuomo full-on on cnn
last night he was just pushing riots i
mean openly pushing riot suggesting that
rioting and looting
are just like the boston tea party okay
there are a few distinctions
with regard to the boston tea party
distinction number one the boston tea
party was directed against the east
india
tea company a monopoly granted by the
british government
so they could gain money off the backs
of american taxpayers
who did not have the ability to vote in
in the british parliament
okay so historically speaking what he is
talking about is nonsense too that was
an act of insurrection
so if what you're talking about is that
the riots and looting are actually acts
of insurrection
and that the federal government has
every force at its disposal to stop acts
of insurrection i suppose that you're
correct
the british government attempted to the
difference is that the british regime
was wrong
i'm wondering exactly how it is wrong to
shut down rioting and looting
and again at least the boston tea party
was targeting a monopoly granted
by the british government i'm not sure
what robbing a target has to do with
police brutality chris cuomo you stupid
ass
here's chris cuomo block of wood
doesn't make it okay to riot says the
majority
but doesn't it depend why it's happening
a riot in boston harbor started the
fight that amounted to america
cities burned across the continent in
1968 again at stonewall
in each of those cases it was the
minority manifesting a desperate plea to
be heard
and for change just like now a friend of
mine
celebrated american and african-american
asked me in a broken voice why doesn't
america love us
why do they do this to us
do do what do what like what is he
talking about
seriously what is he talking about does
it is the impression that americans
are willy-nilly going out and killing
black people is that the apparently
that's the actual impression
not kidding apparently that's the actual
impression so there's a picture that was
going around the internet yesterday
from beverly hills on sunset boulevard a
black man had set up
a a series of nooses and he is dressed
in
in sort of gene cutoffs so that he he's
obviously attempting to look like
a black slave or being being
hanged literally hanged to death on
sunset boulevard with a giant sign that
said 1619-2020
okay this is just i'm sorry
it's just both like
the idea that 16 19 to 20 20 there's
been no progression at all i can think
of a few things that are different
between 16 19 and 20 20.
number one that blacks are now free and
american citizens with full rights as
they always should have been
the most unjust act in american history
was slavery second most unjust act was
jim crow
this guy is in the middle of sunset
boulevard exercising his first amendment
rights under the constitution of the
united states and no one is bothering
him
that is not the same thing as 1965 let
alone 1865
this notion being pushed by the media
that nothing has changed in 400 years
is explicitly a notion directed at the
heart and soul of the united states we
are an evil country and we ought to be
torn out by the roots bernie sanders
was doing this yesterday so bernie
sanders tweeted out
he has not condemned any of the writing
or the looting of course because america
is evil
right this is the bernie sanders
perspective he tweeted out yesterday
the richest 400 americans sit on three
trillion dollars the size of the entire
uk economy
the billionaire class now pays a lower
tax rate than people living paycheck to
paycheck
the looting of america has been going on
for over 40 years
and the corporates are the ultra rich
she says nothing about actual physical
looting but if you run a business
you're a looter and it's been going on
for 40 years
for 40 years america is being looted by
the rich
and nothing to say about riots happening
in the streets where people are
looting businesses nothing to say about
that at all
and then you have people like nicole
hannah jones and nicole hannah jones is
the
editor over at the new york times who
just won a pulitzer for her essay on the
6019 project
a bag of lies so bad that it was ripped
up and down by
a set of other pulitzer prize-winning
historians not only is she
an overrated writer she is an awful
awful historian
so president trump yesterday suggested
that people value their second amendment
rights one of the reasons people value
the second amendment rights is because
if you ain't gonna protect me i'm gonna
protect myself
if you're going to allow rioters and
looters to roam around my neighborhood i
will shoot them if they come on my
property
and you should too okay if people enter
your property looking to riot or loot on
your property
you should be able to shoot them this is
called self-defense that is
uncontroversial it has been
uncontroversial for all of history
in every society if somebody breaks into
your house
of course you have the right to shoot
them and guess what you know who's doing
most of the defending of property right
now
are poor minority shop owners in places
like van nuys
have we've seen situations in poorer
areas where people are stationing
themselves with guns
in their small shops trying to protect
their life savings so what does nicole
hannah jones write she writes
this reference so president trump
referenced the second amendment she says
this reference to the second amendment
is a head scratcher only if you don't
know that the second amendment was in
fact created to ensure southern slave
owners the right to maintain and armed
slave patrols to put down insurrection
among
the enslaved now trump is invoking the
second amendment against their
descendants what the hell
are you talking about i want black
people to be armed against the
predations of other people
white black or green everybody who is a
law-abiding citizen should have the
ability to defend themselves and this is
historically nonsense
absolute sheer absolute nonsense top to
bottom
charles cook the editor of national
review he says the first state to
incorporate an explicit protection
of the right to keep and bear arms was
pennsylvania in 1776.
okay pennsylvania was not a slave
holding state vermont copied that
provision in 1777 in the same document
in which it abolished slavery
pulitzer prize-winning new york times
columnist nicole hannah jones
again the idea here is that america is
racist top to bottom just as racist as
it has ever been
and therefore riding and looting are
okay and therefore any attempt to stop
the rioting and looting is bad and
tyrannical
because obviously these people are are
rioting
and looting in the name of abolishing a
cruel and unjust system
pushing this notion today is ibrahim
kendy who is
another you know sort of famous author
who writes about race
all the time and he's written a couple
of best-selling books
he has a piece over the atlantic that is
called the american nightmare
and let me just no according to the
washington post in 2019
the number of black unarmed men who were
shot black unarmed people were shot by
the police
this according to the washington post
not me the washington post
was nine in a country of 330 million
people with 30 million black people
the number of black unarmed men shot and
killed by police
was nine every one of those is a tragedy
but does that suggest that every black
american is in danger of being shot and
killed by the police
in unarmed fashion by the way the number
of black americans according to the
washington post
unarmed and not fleeing from the police
at the time
shot and killed three
three this is according to the
washington post the the notion again
that blacks are on
are on set for extinction in the united
states is just a lie or that nothing has
happened in the past 200 years or 400
years
this narrative is is dangerous it is
ugly
and it is driving the legitimization of
violence against regime because after
all if the regime
is dedicated to your destruction then
anything you do to resist the regime is
okay
and not only that if every aspect of
american society society is an outgrowth
of a racist regime
and resistance against any institution
including the local target or the local
jewelry store
is an act of resistance against the
regime right you knock over the
institutions of capitalism and you're
knocking over
the institutions of racism according to
the left you see abram kennedy has this
piece
and he he ever this is the most often
played trick
in the in the op-ed world of the left
when it comes to race
it is satan incident from 1896 and then
just fast-forward 120 years and pretend
nothing has happened in the interim
so this is what imbram kennedy does this
is the tanahisi coats trick it is the
jamel bowie trick
and it is ridiculous it's a ridiculous
trick there's this thing called history
and a bunch of crap happened between you
know 1865
and now and between 1965 and now and
between 1968 and now
but here's what he writes says on may
19th 1896 the new york times allocated a
single sentence on page three
to reporting the u.s supreme court's
plessy versus ferguson decision
constitutionalizing jim crow hardly made
news in 1896 there was no there there
americans already knew that equal rights
had been lynched plessy was just the
silently staged funeral
another racial text published by the
nation's premier social science
organization
the american economic association and
classified by historian evelyn hammonds
as one of the most influential documents
in social science at the turn of the
20th century elicited more shock
in 1896 nothing is more clearly shown
from this investigation than that the
southern black man at the time of
emancipation was healthy in body
and cheerful in mind according to
frederick hoffman in race traits and
tendencies of the american negro what
are the conditions 30 years after
hoffman concluded from the plain
language of the fact that black
americans were better off enslaved
okay so what does any of this have to do
is there anyone arguing that black
americans are better off enslaved
anyone who did would be abjectly evil
according to every living human citizen
in the united states with the exception
of like five evil pieces of
human debris but according to abram
kenny nothing has changed
he says a nightmare is essentially a
horror story of danger but it is not
wholly a horror story
black people experience joy love peace
and safety but as in any horror story
those unforgettable moments of toil
terror and trauma have made danger
essential to the black experience in
racist america
what one black american experiences many
black americans experience black
americans are
black americans are constantly stepping
into the toil and terror and trauma of
other black americans
black americans are constantly stepping
into the souls of the dead because they
know
they could have been them they are them
because they know it is dangerous to be
black in america because racist
americans
see blacks as dangerous racist americans
see blacks as dangerous
how about like a stat how about anywhere
in here a stat about the number
of people who are black who are being
murdered by the number of people who are
white for racial reasons because those
stats are available the fbi puts them
out every year
and you know what the number is not high
it is not high because guess what
america is not overwhelmingly racist and
america is not 1896 plessy versus
ferguson
or evil texts like the one he is citing
here by this hoffman person
so what is the jump here's the jump you
ready to be black and conscious of
anti-black racism
is to stare into the mirror of your own
extinction honest to god zebra kennedy
think that he's staring in the mirror of
his own extinction in the united states
does he think that like any moment the
cops are gonna bust down his door and
shoot him just for being black they know
where he lives
white people can figure out where he
lives like
is this is the idea that you are on the
verge of extinction if you are black in
america
because i'm wondering for the evidence
he says ask the souls of the 10 000
black victims of coven 19 who might
still be living if they had been white
what in the actual f are you talking
about
what like what black people were wheeled
into the hospital and all the doctors
took one look at them and they were uh
black guy gonna let him die
there is zero evidence of that the
reason that black americans are dying at
a higher rate than white americans is
because
they are suffering from covenant 19 at a
higher rate than white americans
and part of that has to do with levels
of obesity and levels of diabetes
black britons people who are black
britishers are dying at four times the
rate of white britishers is that because
of endemic british racism as well
he says ask the souls of those blamed
for their own deaths ask the souls of
those who disproportionately lost their
jobs and then their life as others
disproportionately raged about losing
their freedom to infect us all
ah so now if you argued against the
lockdown because you wanted everybody to
be able to get back to work including
people at your business you're racist
ask the souls of those ignored by the
governors reopening their states
because apparently all black and
hispanic people want these states to
remain closed forever
okay there is not a single point of data
that is deployed
in this piece not one it is all simply
the it is all simply
just conjecture abject conjecture
with removing of all confounds the the
only
statistics that are cited in the
entirety of the piece are things like
take minneapolis black residents are
more likely than white residents to be
pulled over arrested and victimized by
its police force
even as black residents account for 20
of the city's population
they make up to they make up 64 of the
people minneapolis police restrained by
the next
since 2018 and more than 60 percent of
the victims of minneapolis police
shootings from late 2009 to may 2019.
question how many of those people were
resisting arrest how many of those
people had committed crimes how many of
those people were reported to have
crimes how many of those people were
armed at the time none of those
statistics make it into the peace
why because any inequality in the data
is obviously inequity because america is
evil
because america is evil right that is
that is what imbram kendy is writing
today over at the atlantic
so the the idea is that the there is
something wrong with society something
dangerous and deathly about racist
policy and black parent people are
experiencing the american nightmare
okay this is the case that the left is
making and making every day
and therefore to shut down the rioting
and the looting is to be a dictator
right it is to be a tyrant the writing
and the looting should be allowed to go
on because the writing and the looting
they are just the natural result
of resistance to an evil regime and that
evil regime of course is the united
states writ large
that is the underlying message here so
don lemon last night on cnn he says
we're teetering on the verge of a
dictatorship
now why because president trump said
that he would use federal forces if need
be to restore order
teetering on a dictatorship this is alex
jones kind of stuff from don lemon
except he's the well-respected cnn
anchor
open your eyes america open your eyes
we are teetering on a dictatorship
we are t this is chaos has the president
i
i'm listening is the president declaring
war on americans
what is happening here he's saying he
wants to protest he wants to protect
peaceful protesters at the same time
sending law enforcement and military
into the streets to push
peaceful protesters back
what you're watching is tyranny because
this is the greatest threat in our
history that's what representative john
yarmuth
tweeted out he said this is the greatest
threat to america in our history
in our history he said the president
just declared war on millions of
americans and the first amendment
he has the greatest threat to the
american way of life in our history
really i i seem to remember jim crown
slavery
being part of american history so what
happened to those is like the greatest
stuff val demings
who is a representative who is widely
considered to be a possible
candidate for vice presidents under joe
biden right it's basically down to
kamala harris and val demings she
tweeted out the president who wouldn't
lift a finger to help americans dying of
covetous 19 will gladly impose martial
law resist
what is what the hell does that mean
resist law enforcement authorities
trying to stop
rioting and looting the only way that
you can get to this conclusion
is to suggest that america deserves what
is coming here
and if not then please speak up and i
think that there are some democrats who
are speaking up i think there's some
democrats who are saying rioting and
looting are bad not every
disintegrationist
is a democrat and not everybody who is
who is critical of the united states is
calling for rioting and looting
but the attempt to conflate the
protesters and the writing and the
looting and declare
tyranny to to stop all of this is
absolutely insane
absolutely crazy okay in a second
we're going to get to the the sort of
moderate position we'll see how these
these conflict i mean
there is the the moderate position here
has fallen away because the the
democrats have made a pitch
that they cannot actually fulfill okay
so
here's the thing once you make the pitch
that democrats have been making for a
very long time and continue
to make that america at root is racist
sexist bigoted homophobic capitalist
tyranny
and once you suggest that writing and
looting are the natural outgrowth of
these things
as you see from don lemon or chris cuomo
who are
overtly defending this sort of activity
and once you suggest
that it is tyranny to stop all of this
that
that it is tyranny to suggest that law
and order be restored
once you do all of this you cannot then
put genie back in the bottle you can't
say well if you just vote
for the right people then magically
everything is healed
and this is the trick that democrats are
trying to play here so
let me give you an example joe biden's
spokeswoman yesterday said that
protesters should rise up i don't know
what that means what does it mean to
rise up what disobey the law
does it mean to write what does this
mean here is joe biden's campaign
spokeswoman
is he dismayed by what he's seen in
terms of of
of the pushback to these the violence
does he feel like some of these
governors could be doing more
he believes that as he has said he
believes that people have a right to
protest
he believes that they should rise up if
you look at
the violence if they should rise up he
has unequivocally condemned the violence
he has said
that we that the the reason that people
are protesting
uh should not be overshadowed by the
protests themselves
okay you're gonna need to be a little
clearer right there you're literally
asked about the violence and they said
they should rise up and then immediately
you say oh but he condemns the violence
hey here's the thing if you said that
you're rising up against an unjust
system
and the system itself is unjust you
can't then put the genie back in the
bottle so this is a trick that president
trump
president obama tried to play yesterday
he put out a piece called how to make
this moment the turning point for real
change
and he says that basically america is
endemically racist this is the same
thing that he has been saying for years
the dna is in the american bloodstream
the racist dna is in america's
bloodstream he says i've heard some
suggest the recurrent problem of racial
bias in our criminal justice system
proves that only protests and direct
action can bring about change and that
voting and participation in electoral
politics is a waste of time
i couldn't disagree more the point of
protest is to raise public awareness to
put a spotlight on injustice
to make the powers that be uncomfortable
in fact throughout american history it's
often only been in response to protests
and civil disobedience that the
political system has even paid attention
to marginalized
communities but eventually aspirations
have to be translated into specific laws
and institutional practices okay here's
where the disconnect comes in
because once you declare the entire
system is bankrupt top to bottom then no
amount of voting within that system is
going to cure the problem
once you suggest that the entire
constitutional structure is ordered in
order to keep black americans down
once you suggest that the entire
american philosophy is corrupt
and cancerous and that it is a tool that
is used by the oppressors in order to
oppress the oppressed
you cannot then claim well if you just
vote within the system then everything
is going to be okay
and this is what protesters are are
recognizing at a visceral gut level
when barack obama says you know yeah go
protest but then vote for your
elected mayor all the mayors in these
cities are democrats and have been for
50 years
they are okay they voted people voted
for the people that barack obama wanted
them to vote for
and guess what those police forces are
still doing all the things that barack
obama says are racist and horrible
and it doesn't matter that eric holder's
justice department crammed down consent
degrees without evidence
against a wide variety of police forces
across the country
none of that matters the bottom line is
that if you claim that the system is
rotten top to bottom you can't then
claim that if you just vote for the
right people within that system
then magically everything will be cured
so in barack obama like
you can't have it both ways you cannot
barack obama wants to have it both ways
and so does joe biden and the protesters
know that
they've been oversold they've been
oversold they've been told the nicole
hannah jones story the 1619 project 400
years of slavery continuing till today
the spike lee
well you know everything is proportional
including violence because after all
violence is done to black bodies every
day in the united states
the protesters hear that rhetoric and
they react to that rhetoric you think
that telling them to go vote for old
slow joe biden is going to
is going to be a motivating factor in
preventing the dissolution of the
country
that's not how this works and and joe
biden humoring this and going along with
it the protester should
rise up says his spokeswoman that right
you think that
the protesters think that rising up
amounts to voting for an 80 year old
white man who sponsored the 1994 crime
bill
does that sound like rising up to you
most protesters
understand on a gut level that what they
are being asked to protest does not
equal the outcome the democrats are
seeking right now
like joe biden was suggesting solutions
yesterday to police brutality
here were his solutions to police
brutality let's teach cops to shoot
people in the leg
like that that's the solution to police
brutality here's joe biden yesterday
the idea that instead of standing there
and teaching a cop when there's an
unarmed person coming at him with a
knife or something shooting a leg
instead of in the heart
is a very different thing there's a lot
of different things that can change
like the idea that if you vote for that
senile old white man
that that is going to fix the problem
that democrats have been labeling as the
root of the united states
for years this career politician from
delaware
sure sure and protesters know that which
is why of course nothing will be
alleviated
by joe biden being elected it may be
papered over because the media will stop
with the the fire breathing
it's time for civil war rhetoric maybe
it'll be papered over for a little while
maybe we'll get fewer essays in the
atlantic about how america is
endemically racist when a democrat is
president after all that story seems to
go away a lot
until it until it doesn't right until
there's ferguson or something
but the the notion that all the problems
are alleviated by electing democrats
that's what barack obama's pushing so
they stoked the flames stoked the flames
stoked the flames and they're like oh
yeah if you just vote for us we'll fix
it that bull
ain't gonna work it is not going to work
that bull crap is not going to work
okay meanwhile i'll tell you something
else that's not going to work
so the media right left and center have
been cheering a variety of
officers kneeling with protesters now
listen officers have to do what they
have to do in order to prevent violence
right now i understand that and
expressing solidarity with people who
don't like police brutality is fine
i see i i severely reject the idea that
kneeling
is the correct symbol here it is not the
correct symbol
kneeling was was taken up by colin
kaepernick as exactly the 1619 project
line america is deeply endemically
racist
america is racist top to bottom and
therefore i'm kneeling for the american
flag because police brutality is
representative
of america more broadly and all police
forces across the nation
and so there's been all sorts of tape of
people celebrating when police officers
take a knee and showing solidarity
listen police officers showing
solidarity with people who are
protesting police brutality is good
taking a knee and agreeing with the sort
of colin kaepernization
kaepernickization of american politics
is a very bad thing because the
underlying message is not true it's a
lie
colin kaepernick was lying about america
kneeling for the american flag is lying
about america
and celebrating when police officers do
this because the cause that is being
pushed here
is not the cause of anti-police
brutality alone because we all agree on
that but the idea that america
is horribly racist across the board
that is that is sheer and absolute
nonsense and it's going to be damaging
and guess what it also is not going to
alleviate the problem either because
let's be frank about this
the first time so there are a bunch of
tapes of police officers expressing
solidarity with citizens protesting
police brutality
and they should that's good right that's
good does anyone believe
for one solitary minute that the next
time there's a
case of police brutality in these cities
that there won't be renewed protests
or riots does anyone believe that
does anyone believe this is going to
last more than the next 15 seconds it's
a defusing of the situation in front of
the cops i get that
but does anyone actually believe that
let's say that so yesterday there was
tape of that nypd chief of police
hugging protesters first of all just
want to note here that the entire media
were shaming you as murder and grandma
if you if you went out in public without
a face mask
50 feet from every other human being now
you're supposed to hug protesters with
no mask
in public in new york in crowds with no
one wearing a mask
and no one cares there's a celebratory
moment
okay so and watch the way the media will
play this then there will be an uptick
in the number of coveted cases over the
next two weeks and then it'll be oh look
there's an uptick in the number of covet
cases and it's targeting black and
hispanic communities
okay you can't have it both ways if
you're going to say that the protests
don't that the protests
are deeply important and so we are going
to ignore all the coveted regulations
because we like these protests
and those protests are
disproportionately minority and then
there's a disproportionate outbreak from
the protest
okay that's not american racism that's
just called cause and effect
okay but put aside all the covet of all
of this and it is indicative
of the media's insanity that the the hot
take here is that covid is only
something we're talking about when we're
talking about
lockdown protests but when you have tens
of thousands of people marching in the
street and screaming
and getting spit all over each other
right which is what you do in your
protest that that's totally okay but
does anyone believe that's the nypd
chief of police the next time
that there's an issue with police
brutality or disputed circumstance with
police
does anyone believe that if the nypd
chief of police comes out and says we
all oppose this stuff that he's going to
be believed
seriously does anyone does anyone think
that's what's going to happen does
anyone think that when the the police
officer is in seattle
go out there and kneel with the
protesters that the next time
there's an incident that gets caught on
tape of a disputed circumstance with a
cop
that the next wave of protesters can be
like oh no you know they're good guys i
remember last time when they kneeled
with us
i remember last time when they came out
and showed solidarity with us does
anyone believe that that's what's going
to happen
the answer of course is no because none
of this actually solves the underlying
problems
the underlying problem is manifest
distrust between a large swath of
american citizens and the police
and the attempts to bridge that trust
gap by having the police express
sympathy
for the population that's that's good
they should by the way cops do this
routinely when they're not on tape cops
do this all the time all the time
but the the idea that if you kneel with
people and and
admit generalized american racism that
this is somehow going to alleviate the
problem
it's not true because all that's going
to happen is the next time something
happens they're going to say
even you recognize that american racism
is a root
of this entire problem so here's all i'm
saying
express sympathy everyone is on the same
page on police brutality for the one
millionth time
express sympathy for people who are
fighting against police brutality but do
not admit to the lie
that america is in favor of police
brutality that america is endemically
racist that america is incurably racist
that the american system is attempting
to exterminate black people it is not
true and police are doing themselves and
no one else any favors
by exceeding in that particular line of
attack
you want to go out and give people hugs
go for it seriously like go for it aside
from all the covid stuff go for it like
what the nypd chief
does right there giving people hugs is
significantly i think it's positive i
think that's good
kneeling using the symbology
of the colin kaepernick america is evil
betsy ross's flag is a symbol of racism
movement
that's not good for the country it's not
unifying and that unity is going to last
approximately another 27 seconds until
there's another bad tape that comes out
at which point the unity immediately
dissipates and we go back to the endemic
levels of mistrust that have been
promulgated by the media and will
continue to be promulgated by the media
no matter what the cops do
and meanwhile today is apparently
they're calling it uh blackout tuesday
so blackout tuesday is basically a bunch
of companies
now saying that they are not going to do
business today and putting out
woke statements about the about the
levels of racism
in american society which begs the
question if you guys are also racist
name the racists on your board and fire
them
right really i mean if if you have to
come out and say this like i don't know
who needs to hear from corporate america
which again it's illegal to engage in
racially discriminatory activity as a
private business in the united states
that's illegal by federal law but
and by every state's law too by the way
but
if they're racist within your midst
let's let's hear about them like who are
they and what are they doing and
how are they impacting policy and let's
but what this really is is now we have
reached the point
where basically businesses are afraid
that they are going to be blackmailed if
they do not put out
social justice warrior statements about
how america is endemically racist
corporations are out there to make money
they understand that the
levels of risk attendant in not making
quote unquote anti-racist statements is
very high now again
i'm not saying that people aren't
entitled to their opinions that
corporations can't put out these
statements they absolutely can but i'm
telling you you're a sucker if you
believe that foot locker
is is spending each and every day
considering the 1619 project as opposed
to
they see people who are pressuring them
outside and now they are attempting to
basically buy their way into your good
graces by putting out an ad
by the way which is not going to work
nike got looted last night in new york
city nike put out an ad about how
america was was horribly racist and we
can't
don't do it but who is like that ad was
so ridiculous don't do it who's doing it
are you putting your knee on the neck of
a black person today i'm not
that's called evil nobody's doing it
except that one cop who's gonna go to
jail
and should go to jail because it was
atrocious it was an atrocity
but nike tried to buy its way into the
good graces of the social justice
warrior left and that is a dangerous
thing because here's the thing the
social justice warrior left isn't just
involved in attempting to push a lie
about america more broadly
once they have their foot wedged in the
door then they can militarize all of
american business in favor of their
favorite political causes
and this is what you've seen the hard
left doing for a long time
right if you if you disagree with the
hard left on an issue
they will then suggest that you are not
woke enough and they will have you fired
from your job this is part of the
this is part of the politicization of an
area of american life that does not need
to be political and
and should not be political target
should not be political it shouldn't
that means that they that doesn't that
doesn't mean that they should be
pro-racist
again the the conflation of anti-racist
with agreeing with everything that
ta-nehisi coates writes is absolutely
asinine
target is not racist because they don't
discriminate against black customers
target does not need to put out
statements
about black lives matter because target
is a store they are not involved in
killing black people
they're not involved in discriminating
against black people the attempt to
impute guilt to people who do not repeat
your preferred formulations is utterly
insane
and and ideologically tyrannical
it turns out that silence does not mean
that somebody opposes you maybe silence
is because
that's not in their purview it is not
indi
you know we hear this rightly with
regard to terrorist attacks so every
time there's a terrorist attack
there are a bunch of people who say
let's say it's a muslim terrorist attack
a radical islamist terrorist attack
they're a bunch of people who will say
things like
the muslim community is not obligated to
come out and condemn terror attacks
because they weren't involved in the
terror attack
i kind of agree with that i i don't
think it's up to every jew
to condemn something bad when a jew does
it and i don't think it's up to every
black person to condemn something bad
when a black person does it
and i don't think it's up to every white
person to condemn something bad when a
white person does it or one white person
did it 150 or 200 years ago
and i don't think it's the job of target
to condemn activity in which they were
not involved
the attempt to hold people accountable
for activities in which they are not
involved so you can get them
to basically repeat your preferred
nostroms of the day is really dangerous
it's really dangerous because it doesn't
allow any area where we can be
apolitical
it doesn't allow any area where you are
allowed to disagree basically
silence will be taken as resistance to
the dominant social justice warrior
narrative
and then as an excuse to hurt you well
target didn't put out its virtue
signaling statement today that means
it's time to loot target obviously
they're not anti-racist it's not enough
to be
against racism you have to be actively
anti-racism and target didn't put out a
statement if you believe that the
shareholders the target
or the board at target were motivated by
pure
unbridled belief in black lives matter
to put out statements as opposed to you
know public pressure
then you're wrong and if you believe
that that sort of pressure is good for
the country
get ready for a lot more a lot more
polarization in the country
because guess what most people just want
to be left alone most people just want
to be left alone
and most people are not appreciative of
the root justification
for this kind of stuff which is if you
don't say anything
about the black lives matter system it's
because you don't care about black lives
most people don't want to be bullied
into opinions they don't want to be
bullied into opinions with the
implication
that if you disagree with my specific
agenda it's because you're a horrible
person
as opposed to maybe we just have
differences in our viewpoint
so again corporate cowardice combined
with
pressure tactics by the media the
country is uh becoming
a uh a worse place every day because of
these things again in a time when we
should all agree on this stuff
we should all agree on this stuff the
attempt to polarize on stuff where we
all agree is
insane insane alrighty well we'll be
back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pablo wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan associate producer katie
swinerton
edited by adam sciavitz audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you want to cut through the madness
of our politics and culture and know
what's really going on head on over to
the michael knowles show where we can
all bask
in the simple joys of being right see
you there
[Music]
you